live Zoom as that gives you the
opportunity to interact with Dr Wallach
and even ask your questions from Dr
Wallach so if you have a question for Dr
Wallach and you'd like to join us live
again go to daily with Doc zoom.com
and you'll be able to join us here live
I just want to welcome everybody if you
were invited by somebody specific don't
forget to get back with them and tell
them thank you for inviting you to this
program this is a special honor that we
have to be able to jump on here with Dr
Wallach as he takes time
to continue continue the message of Hope
this is part of his schedule this is
what he does every day several times a
day and the fact that he includes Us in
it I feel greatly honored and as the
hostess of this program I am honored to
be the hostess of daily with Doc Zoo
today so anyways my name is Becca dukes
and I want to say
the Food Supplies around the world are
null and void of the nutrition that we
need in order to do more than just
survive folks I don't know about you
or where you're at in your health
Journey right now
but I was
not surviving in fact there were days
where I was hoping I would make it
through the day
and when I started giving my body the
nutrition that it needed I got my life
back and started to thrive not just
barely survive and the information that
is going to be shared today is going to
be very beneficial in helping you to do
the same
so as we are going through we do have a
special guest that we are waiting for
um
in addition to of course Dr Wallach
being a special guest but Dr Wallach you
have been a lifetime learner
you have been feeding into the lives of
so many people around the world
and it doesn't matter who they are
you love people
you love to
lift people up and give them hope
because you yourself
being somebody that nobody wanted to be
around as a child
found that and now you're able to share
it with others
so I just want to thank you well I and
folks
I don't care if it offends you or not
I'm praising God that got used Dr
Wallach
to make such an impact
and have him go through everything that
he has gone through to be able to share
his story today
so
Dr Wallach
well thank you Becca and your team for
the kind introduction and your presence
and everything you do and the
consistency of everything you do and
again today we're hoping and praying
that um Theo gets here because he was to
be the featured guest but we'll start
out with his story
um some years ago of course I I I'm only
uh what five foot six I think when I'm
Standing Tall
five foot two and I'm slouching okay and
it's one of those things where I'm I'm
not a basketball player because I'm too
sharp with Theo
um
I met him his uh Pastor actually brought
him to us
because he had lost his position with
the Atlanta Hawks he'd been playing with
him after he graduated college
and um you know basketball of course
Atlanta Hawks and he had bone arthritis
and both his leg now he's 24 years old
he had bone to bone arthritis in both
his knees
he had the cartilage slipping off his
hips
he had a fracture in his shooting arm
wrist his right wrist and so he lost his
contract about one year into his
three-year contract with the Atlanta
Hawks there's like a 30 million dollar
contract because he he's a shooter okay
he was good a Defender he was good
and his Pastor brought him to me and
says you know I understand you're
working with athletes boxers and people
in basketball and football and stuff
what about basketball I said well now
let's talk to Theo she brought Theo over
and sure enough I said well yes sir we
can do something for you
and what I did was I took our we already
knew about the 90 essential nutrients
we're already going that direction the
90 cents nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 measles Three fatty acids
which was the basic necessities of all
human beings especially those doing
physical stress including Sports
but because he had all the stuff going
on with all his cartilage and connective
tissue and disc and
um all this kind of stuff
um we came up with a collagen product we
call it glucogel
okay we added the glucogel collagen
product to the healthy Bone and Joint
pack or the Healthy Start pack called
the healthy Bone and Joint pack and and
brought to seal got them taken it two
three times a day
and in six months time
he gets another position with
professional basketball
okay to make a long story short
he played for 11 more years
made a hundred million dollars and he
buys with that money he buys this
facility which is a rehab facility on
many many acres of land in Georgia and
he uses it to help disabled kids that
are emotionally disabled psychologically
disabled and physically disabled and he
does that for the community I just I
thought that was so great for him to do
that
and of course if you look at the cans of
rebound if you look at the canister or
the powder rebound I don't think it's on
the box of the sticks but on the on the
canister's rebound there's a picture of
Theo and the cans of rebound there's a
picture of Theo
and of course I think it was probably a
a year or two into it where he became
famous again and he was a shooter he was
just Unstoppable
and so he came up with his four string
for him
rebound to compete with a Red Bull
and it's really you know the the
um story of
of
um
what'd you say energy drinks for
athletes is kind of a sad story a Red
Bull became you know the primary one I
mean it was a big guy okay it still is
the biggest one I think but a couple of
months ago uh God the name of dietrich's
uh Magic tips who was one of the
co-founders of Red Bull died at age 78
and he'd been bragging for years where
he'd been drinking 20 25 cans of Red
Bull a day
okay for over 20 years and he dies at 78
and
um and this is really a terrible story
when you think about it okay
and Red Bull only has one mineral on it
only has the mineral magnesium in it
and then you go back to
1973 when Bruce Lee died of a heart
attack he was only 32 years old and he
was considered the fitness Guru he was
considered the fitness athlete a very in
every country in the world and he was
invited to speak at graduations at
colleges and speak to professional teams
and Olympic teams all over the world and
he dies of a heart attack at age 32
because he only settlement with one
mineral
magnesium because doctors convinced him
don't waste your money on vitamins and
minerals just take you know just eat
well you get everything you need and
unfortunately he believes the doctors
okay instead of us and he died at age 32
of heart attack terrible terrible story
okay a good story turned terrible
but anyway
um Theo has done such a great job he
continues to be a community person he
continues to
um uh go around the world and share his
story and you know bring young athletes
along and make sure that they know his
story so they can take the 90s sense of
nutrients and do the rebound and so
forth
we can't thank Theo enough for this okay
because there's literally I would say
there's tens of thousands
of
people
every hour
every day every week every month around
the world
who use our program with the rebounds
for shrink and the healthy Bone and
Joint pack for their bones and joints
okay
because of Theo's story and he is
um
what
um Bruce Lee should have been because he
has been doing this with us I don't know
exactly I was you know I was going to
get the exact time from Theo but it's
like 25 years or more okay 25 years or
more Theo's been with us bringing all
this information to people
okay saving kids
um having kids you know who grew up in
very what should I say
um
districts are very big bad places
they're living to get into college
because they they gain skills and
strength because of our our Sports diet
our healthy Bone and Joint pack and also
our rebound and going on to play
basketball to play football to wrestle
like I did to get into boxing like my
father did and get into all these Sports
track and weightlifting and and so forth
because of our rebound so very very
proud of that and I apologize because
you know we thought Theo was going to be
here and maybe he got the times mixed up
because he's on the East Coast
we'll see but anyway we do have a a set
a three CD set that I want everybody
that has somebody in their family who
exercises who's somebody in their family
who works in some place where they do a
lot of physical labor right for somebody
who's going to school junior high high
school
um grade school college okay they're in
the military
all right I retire as Lieutenant curl in
the Air Force so I know about the
military
and so CD number one is dead athletes
don't lie talked about a lot of famous
athletes died in their 20s and 30s
because they weren't taking the 90s
nutrients and then the second serious
oh see you on now
is I think he's on yeah they always said
to you
asked to unmute
okay I'll keep going until you unmute
okay so okay so the second CD is
exercise without supplementation of
suicide
okay because when you exercise you're
not just
losing water in your sweat you're losing
nutrients and if you're just drinking
water to rehydrate you're not going to
make it that's why there's so many
athletes in their 20s and 30s and 40s
that die of what's called a hypertrophy
carnabity of heart disease which in
little infants is called sediment death
syndrome okay we found out the
conjuncture well we can't say cure when
we found out the conservention of it in
these infants and in athletes when they
get diagnosed if they don't just die on
the court or in the field or in the
shower but they do have a heart attack
we can rehab them okay within 90
nutrients and these what we call the
secret sauces for this particular
deficiency
the third CDN is set is what kills
billionaires what kills billionaires
these three CDs everybody should get
this CD set and listen to it if it give
it his gifts to their family
because even if they're not going to be
professional athletes
okay
even if they're just an exercise that
walked around the block they need this
information because
exercise without supplementation is
suicide okay now did we were able to hit
Theo on
he is here with us Dr Wallach we're
working on sound Theo if you could try
unmuting again let's see
if we still have an echo
okay
I'm about to go outside
um yeah I was in the gym so
with
all right
left in the house with us thank you so
much Theo for joining us here on daily
with doc Dr wellick was just giving an
introduction of
um your story and how the two of you met
and I'm so excited to have both of you
here with us today and when you are
positioned where you can turn your
camera on I'd like to have both of you
up here on the screen
so that we can see you both in a
conversation
yeah because I need some dates from Theo
Theo you're there
yeah hold on a second
he's getting situated Dr Wallach okay
I'm walking to my car right now
okay all right fantastic okay because
I'm gonna find out exactly when your
pastor put us together okay I want to
know how many years ago it was okay and
um
what professional teams you played for
and so for that kind of stuff
tell me when you're ready
and it's one of those great stories it
was a story that it was the never-ending
story because it always added to it and
Theo just kept on going and adding to it
and so it's one of those great stories
that needs to be told over and over and
over because there's so many people who
um wind up with injuries unnecessarily
who get injuries and and don't get
proper treatment unnecessarily there's
people who die prematurely unnecessarily
okay because they don't get the
information
and again the three CD set is actually
put together as a CEO story uh dead
athletes don't lie exercise those
limitation of suicide and what kills
billionaires and you have to appreciate
that just drinking water after the
exercise rehydrate is suicidal because
sweat is not just water sweat contains
all the the nutrients floating around
your blood
when you're sweating them out I mean
you're exercising heavily twice a day
and then you know playing
um on teams and that kind of stuff hey
Doc look up
hello we're good okay there's Theo okay
so let's see here when did we get
together what year was that when you
when the past 12 in 2002
2002.
everything was going to ride for me I
know it was going good everything was
going going great until it wasn't oh
okay
28 years ago 21 years ago yeah so 2002
um I met Phil Oliver and Mike Glenn who
you guys might know that's a part of the
uh distribution team uh here in Atlanta
um after I had just got traded after
making an All-Star Game breaking my
wrist and
um and also during that summer after I
had recovered from the wrist injury I
just took a routine jump and I ended up
tearing my legroom
in my hip
so everything was just falling apart and
um I met those guys they they spoke to
me about
um have I ever heard of mineral
deficiencies and I'm like what is that I
have no clue what that is and so they
was like man I need need to introduce
you to a doctor Joel Wallach
I need you to introduce you to a doctor
Joel Wallach who is
basically help
to
help to treat
the I mean we'd call it the pig pack
plus before the arthriters and pigs and
different things of that nature and all
these different treatments that he's
done through his veterinary medicine and
he's took it into his practice of
being a doctor through human human
medicine so uh through human um uh using
minerals for the human body to heal
different things of the same diseases
that plague the animals so
I was kind of skeptical at first and it
kind of sounded crazy
were you talking about you know the
human in the mix
um you know especially with me being
young but
as I did my due diligence and and
understood exactly where it was coming
from where he's talked about you're not
gonna give an animal
a hundred dollar pill
in order to
supplement some of the disease and
injuries that he that he has you're
gonna find a nutritional way which is a
lot cheaper
to be able to help
um cure certain things and animals so uh
with that said he when he formulated uh
America uh longevity at first uh he
created
that platform to be able to utilize it
with you know with with their human body
so
um I've been taking the product like I
said now 20 something years
um going strong still going strong
um just had some a few minutes ago right
before the workout with the boys so so
um it's something that I do on a daily
basis
um to just maintain my health even after
playing uh 16 years in the NBA so
um it's a great product
um we love doctor death I mean he's like
I say he's been a savior for me because
I say in in 2001 after I did the labor
room tear
um and trying to recover
um the problem was I wasn't healing
and I thought I was gonna have to retire
so as I got on the nutrients and my body
started building back I got stronger
stronger and stronger as I was with the
uh Atlanta Hawks and I ended up winning
uh two more
two two defensive uh block shot
championships
um led the league in Black side for two
years
for two years uh two years in a row
um after that
um so and then signed a nice big
contract
which you know I love and appreciate you
that
we're just telling your story is good
enough we appreciate your story I have
to I have to ask you a question so let
me interrupt you let me ask you a
question
oh okay
um when it comes to
your healing story
you did something with some of your
money you bought this facility
uh what would you call it is it a rehab
center or a training center what is it
you
oh I have a no I have an activity center
that I don't know through the foundation
yeah what Foundation Community Center uh
back home in Demopolis okay
the different projects and you know
people can come in play basketball we
have uh uh computer center where the
adults can learn how to work computers
kids everybody as a as a whole Compass
the whole Community
um how long have you been running that
to facilities there for the community
that facility been in existence for at
least 15 years 15 years okay so it's
very thoughtful of you to spend you know
a lot of people just take the money and
run the fact that you invested in your
community invested in your family
invested in the state
um we're really so very very proud of
you that you did such a great job uh in
healing yourself okay and of course
we're glad we were able to contribute to
that and you stayed away from all the
bad stuff you didn't do street drugs and
you didn't you know do alcohol and all
that kind of stuff you did nutrition so
we're very very proud of you and thank
you thank you thank you for taking care
of the community with your facility we
really are so proud of you for that a
great product came out of this as well
because when I came back which helped me
you know get those block shot titles and
second team defensive play of the year
and all those different Hercules that I
got through the NBA was that good old
rebound Doc is holding the cans up right
now and also the the stick yeah oh I
call it the magic stick the magic stick
there you go
yes you can run you can take it anywhere
you want with you uh put it in by eight
ounces of water and you're good to go
your energy is high and all things are
well
here you go it's one of those things
where you know you've created an entire
which they say community okay because
the the previous energy drinks were
primarily sugar and caffeine are
anything our rebound has 75 minerals in
it and 25 vitamins amino acids it has
like
um I don't know 25 of the sugar and 25
of the caffeine that Red Bull has in it
and Red Bull only has one mineral and it
only has magnesium in it we have 75
minerals in rebound so we're very very
proud of you and of course at home I
drink the cans by pop the tops and at
night put them in the refrigerator so
they're flat in the morning all the
carbonation is gone but when I get an
airplane like you say we're going out to
dinner some at night I'd take the sticks
with me uh and tear the top off and put
them in a little bottle of water and
drink them
and so I go through at least two full
doses of the rebound a day and I only
weigh 142 pounds
you lost weight
yeah I did lose a little bit of weight I
had gotten up to about 160. it was my
high point we got up to about 160 and
um and so but that's because I was
eating four or five meals a day and I'm
back down to the HSN two two nice meals
today and having at lunch I'll have uh
some of our triple treat chocolate at
our some cheese sticks along with the
rebound and that's my lunch but I'll
have two big uh of breakfast and a big
dinner time okay I like my steaks I like
my eggs and I like I like all that stuff
and we can't thank you enough
um because you've been such a good
example to Young athletes coming along
Theo you didn't do drugs you didn't do
abuse alcohol and so we're so very very
proud of you for all the things you've
done uh for uh kids for America for
Humanity in the world so we're very
proud of you for all you've done yeah
doc I tried to try to school them every
time I get a chance
so let's School some people not just
athletes because I've got a question
here on YouTube wanting to know if
rebound is just for athletes
oh of course of course not I mean
anytime you need a pick-me-up energy
wise and also it has the minerals in it
as well so that that was one of the main
purposes uh for God creating it and so I
can replenish minerals or you can
replenish minerals as you work out or if
you just need a boost and you need some
some good nutrition it's better than
grabbing you know the Gatorades and
different things in nature day gives you
nothing but like you said sugar and
water
there you go
so I have a couple questions Theo
you were breaking bones
tearing tendons
ligaments Dr mentioned uh hip Capsule
that's painful I've torn a hips capsule
and he said that yours was slipping off
something like that and I wasn't an
athlete
so you had put your body through a lot
as a team
and you were experiencing that hap you
started filling all of these effects at
how old
um well unbeknownst to me it was it was
going on because I mean when you're
young you just you just playing through
stuff but you know as I
started going into the NBA and they
started telling me I had degenerative
tissues and knees and different things
then they adjust from the long term of
being from playing from elementary all
the way through through college
um but they still drafted me anyway so
they they feel that I could I could last
but I would probably start suffering
some injuries you know right around that
fifth sixth year and it happened just
like they said it would and my body
started falling apart so
um so yes it was uh yeah it was it was a
tough road and it started early on
um you know even through early as
College
College days
so what I take from this video is you
don't wait until you're starting to feel
the negative effects of a working your
body well definitely don't worry because
like I say I had what I had was early it
would be I was like I was an older man
you know you know I was developing
osteoporosis like a you know the vitamin
D the minimal I mean and you know with
what what the minerals brought with I
swear with the Ico FX and magnesium they
brought those that uh ability to be able
to get the calcium up the vitamin D up
and all those things to help you know
strengthen my bones at the same time you
had the uh gelatin the glucose gel and
everything helping their clothing uh
coat the joints
um to rebuild cartilage and different
things that nature that helped me like I
said continue to play 10 more years in
the NBA and if it's all Built For You
Theo hahaha
well he he like pushed you
to put something together Dr Wallach
but what has come of this formulation to
help Theo can now help anybody and
everybody I know it helped me
I had the digit of bone and disc disease
30 years old the neurologist that was
looking at my MRI walked in and walked
back out because he thought he was
coming to see somebody 65 to 70 years
old in poor health oh wow so folks I
mean Theo
if you don't believe my story here we
have Theo
that has taken the nutrients
and it has made such an impactful
I mean he gave him his life back it gave
him his career back allowed him to be
able to continue the career that he
loved for many many years making enough
money to make a even larger impact in
his community
where he lives
plus be an example folks
of it's not too late
and for us as parents and grandparents
and even kids that are listening to this
if you're active
or I'm gonna say for me I was living in
Phoenix I did a lot of sweating
of course on the farm I did a lot of
stuff but I was not an athlete
you take the nutrients all the time
starting as early as absolutely possible
to give your body what it needs so that
it can Thrive from the beginning and
keep on going
now Theo you're no longer an athlete
are you still taking the nutrients
Oh Yes actually you are still an athlete
I mean you're working out with your kids
and there you go he's got them right
there he got muted
we all work out with the kids
um like I said it's it's something that
you know it is a part of me
I try to take it every time every time I
get a chance uh every day every day of
the week
when I was nine years old is when I
started at least four times a week for
sure
the lifestyle
you're investing in
Wellness
right
and I think there is nothing better
yep and like doc said it
um when he when he when they talked
about their number pills like the
gelatin pills and the EFA pills it was
like it's it's natural so it's not like
you're taking pharmaceutical drugs so
don't be alarmed you have to take six
pills that's always the biggest hurdle
for people when I talk to them about it
like six bills no I'm not taking six
pills because it's natural to just take
one two uh pharmaceutical drugs and then
you know you get the effects or whatever
it is but with this it's it's natural so
whatever it is that you put into your
body it absorbs in your body is not
going to cause any side effects or
different things of that nature which is
always you know a great thing so yeah I
think you made a good point too that um
the medications deal with the symptoms
and don't get to the basic root cause of
the problem where these nutrients get to
the basic root cause of the problem
which is a totally different approach so
thank you for pointing that out
well and think about it we're using food
as medicine
right are you gonna feel a bit filled up
and fortify your body with just one
little pill that chemically Alters
the body and its response to pain
no
you're not so folks when doc doc goes
through he takes he takes a lot I've
seen it I don't take that much
and I still had great results and I
still feel great
and you can too
so we invite you to give Dr wallach's
formulas 90 days
I mean you're gonna start feeling the
difference don't stop
don't stop keep going right Theo he is
consistency
[Music]
I'm going to take this for at least
10 years after I die I'm gonna make sure
they put a 10-year supply of a solution
and send to my coffin when I die
do you want it in the bottle or
yeah just pour it on
no just you know you know just in the
containers
I don't want to answer to get any of it
uh Dr Wallach well so Theo
what do you see in your future
what other big plans do you have that
you're now able to do whether it's
because of your MBA career because of
what you have found in youngevity
well mainly these these guys right here
hi guys
oh look at that
yeah so just uh continue to be be Daddy
we coach
and try to you know understand
what proper nutrition is and what it can
do for them as well
so I can get them to take it every now
and then
well that's it's one of God's greatest
um what should I say paths is to do good
things for the next generation and your
fellow people in your generation we
cannot thank you enough for sharing all
that you've done because you have been a
light in the darkness because you stuck
with it you are still doing it and you
know you're still out there being
physical and how old are you now
well I'm about to turn 50 next week
you're gonna turn 50 the big five oh
whoa all right well congratulations
it's a blessing
yes happy early birthday happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you so we'll be
the first ones to sing a happy birthday
Theo and I know you and the kids are out
and you're busy taking some time out to
join us here we just greatly appreciate
you and thank you for for all that
you've done I know doc talks about you
all the time yes I appreciate it you're
one of God the greatest angels and we
love you foreign yeah thank you back
so all right
all right
go get some of that good rebound
get the minerals in your life changes in
life
that's right that's right awesome well
thank you so much Thea we appreciate you
you've been such an inspiration to many
including Dr Wallach
Revolution your stories in this book
there's a 75-year journey and there's
all these great stories in there and
Theo's story is one of them an
impossibility is based on nutrition and
of course we cannot thank you enough
um for you know being uh this story in
this book the wallet Revolution now
there's there you go there's dozens of
stories in there okay these are some of
my major
successes now we couldn't get all 600
in there okay we do have dozens of major
stories in here and Theo's story is one
of them because he was a mess okay there
is no way he was going to come back and
play professional basketball with bone
to bone arthrash in his knees they
wanted to give him double knee
replacement the cartilage was slipping
off his hips they want to give him
double hip replacement he fractured his
shooting wrist
um uh okay his right hand and you know
nobody comes back from that well he did
because he gave up all the bad stuff
when she wasn't doing much of but he did
take all the good stuff Faithfully
he recovered very quickly he came back
got a new contract
and played for 11 more years and then of
course he contributed to his community
and the surrounding community and
Humanity by getting this facility and we
cannot praise him enough for that
yeah I think it's awesome as I'm going
through looking at the comments
um here
um out on YouTube uh we have sporta says
that Theo was the fastest hardest
working big man in the league when he
was at the Sixers just awesome and then
we have Z Captain says Theo's maybe the
best shot blocker ever
so there's a lot of people that remember
what he has done in the NBA and all of
his successes and Dr Wallach you are
part of that and I'm so very excited
that we are able to be able to present
him to to our community
also so folks if you are watching and
you know somebody who has kids they're
active in sports
if you know somebody that is active
themselves in sports
please share this program with them
be part of what keeps them from having
all of this degeneration that trust me
is very painful
you've heard the message
it's your obligation to share it
just to help somebody else not suffer or
to stop the suffering
now we cannot guarantee that our and we
cannot say that our products diagnose
prevent cure any diseases but folks your
body was designed to Contin continually
be recreating
and growing
and if you've got the raw ingredients
that it needs to create healthy cells
you're going to have healthier cells
I mean it's like the liver Dr Wallach
people can have cirrhosis of the liver
stage four get on the nutrition take out
the bad foods
decontaminate their insides with
nutrients by flooding the bodies with
nutrients and the liver can come back
yeah the liver had enormous capacity to
heal itself
and so so do muscle
and the connective tissue the skin
all of these things that based on what
we put into our bodies
the outcome
can be positive or negative
and we are empowered to play a big part
in that and Dr Wallach your formulas
your research that went into them
has been so impactful in so many lives
that I just can't thank you enough for
all that you have done I know we have
just a few more minutes I want to make
sure that everybody gets back with the
person that shared this program with
them
thank them if there's nobody to think
feel free to go to daily
withdoc.com we do have a contact us
there we I know we didn't get to many
questions today I'm going to try to get
to a couple
but use that contact us send us your
questions and if you have never spoken
to anybody about youngevity before
anybody about Dr Wallach feel free to
contact my call team at
855-949-3377 but again that is for
people who have not already been in
communication with somebody about Dr
Wallach and Dr and the youngevity
products
so Dr Wallach let's go to
um hand up and and I know that the order
is not right because
the co-hosts when they have their hands
up it doesn't come in the right order
but
Phyllis
go ahead and unmute yourself and come on
I know you had a question for a client
that we were talking about before the
show so your hand was up first
uh yes doc I've got a question for Helen
she's not on the zoom she's 80 years
young retired military five foot four
150 pounds no medication now you have
already advised her on a few things
you've talked to her a couple of times
about Ms
sciatica in tinnitus and she religiously
avoids the bad foods and she is a
vegetarian but she's eating eggs in as
much healthy fat as she can
and I think this is hard to believe she
may take more product than you do she
probably takes several servings of the
brain and heart pack copious other
products so here's her question her legs
are below the knee are chronically
slightly swollen with tight muscles in
her calves recently one leg is a little
more swollen feels warm and red up to
the knee
um got a brown patch near her ankle with
blistery skin she's been putting
colloidal silver on it which seems to
help what are your thoughts on that uh
red swollen leg
well she needs to add two things for a
program number one the ultimate daily
classic Talos three words ultimate daily
classic tablets that'll Supply greater
blood flow okay and blood flow support
to all areas of the body including the
ankles and the feet and the legs and the
knees and the hips and and the back and
so forth okay and the brain and then
also if there's any blood pressure
issues going on there it'll support
healthy blood pressure if she's on any
blood pressure medication don't cold
turkey off of that but as the blood
pressure improves she can slowly reduce
the blood pressure medication based on
the numbers
and then
we do have if she has pain anywhere we
do have the hemp FX soothe okay put a
couple of spritzes of that where she has
a pain and it'll give her about four to
six hours of pain relief and um I love
it okay because I still do a lot of
exercise in this and the other walking
and that kind of stuff and so
every once in a while pull something and
I use that soothe okay it's called hemp
FX and it's it's legal and um you know I
buy six of those tubes at a time and
when I get down to the last two I'll buy
six more tubes you know the six tubes
will last me about a year okay for pain
relief all right swelling swelling
relief anti-inflammatory
and then
um let's see here I think uh she's
covering it
um with what she's doing but don't
forget that I also throw in the MSM if
she doesn't is not taking the MSM she's
MSM is her body weight she could take
three three times a day it'll be two
bottles a month of MSN big bottles and
they will support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between a vertebrae bone rakes bone
itself the skin
um re walls anything made out of
collagen and connective tissue will be
benefited by the MSM
okay
perfect thank you so much okay well God
bless you and you know give us a call
every couple weeks and let us know how
she's doing sure will thank you okay
all right thank you Phyllis and let's go
right over to Gloria Gloria go ahead and
unmute if you would you're on live with
Dr Wallach
hi Gloria what's up
Gloria can you unmute yes there you go
and let me stop the video uh my question
I'm sorry I have laryngitis
um
my question is about my cholesterol a
year and a half ago I was 283 and two
weeks ago went up to 309.
I am gluten free I don't need junk don't
drink junk the only thing I'm doing
different is having the three eggs every
morning as you're advised
and my smoothies I add protein and a lot
of fruit I love fruit so I put it in my
smoothies and the protein to supplement
because I lost five pounds and I want to
get them back because I'm not under 16.
yeah so I I'm the opposite so okay let's
walk there let's stop there for a minute
okay cholesterol cholesterol is not a
bad thing cholesterol does not block
arteries it was a misrepresentation by
doctors 100 years ago they missed it by
a million miles cholesterol does not
cause blocked arteries fried foods and
salad dressings and cooking oils is what
causes blocked arteries
cholesterol makes up 25 of your brain
weight normal brain weight as the white
matter of rain okay
the cholesterol makes up 25 of your
spinal cord weight okay
it's called myelin the white matter of
the brain as a white matter of the brain
and white matter of the spinal cord or
100 cholesterol okay
and so
um to have your blood cholesterol up
above 100 is not a bad thing you just
need to not be frying anything uh you
know no Fried Chicken no fried fish no
fried potatoes no fried vegetables no
fried eggs nothing fried okay I don't
okay good
but um yeah so do not take cholesterol
lowering drugs
okay uh cholesterol lowering drugs will
cause you to really be in trouble you'll
wind up getting Alzheimer's disease you
wind up with Ms you wind up with uh
those kind of things
so
um also there's a new one out
um
uh FTD frontal temporal dementia which
is kind of a Alzheimer's disease which
deals with the front and the temporal
parts of the brain and the whole back
half of the brain is normal
doctors can't figure that one out well
that's all because where the blood
supply is and so forth and uh you know
these are people who are taking statin
drugs or avoiding cholesterol
be and that's why they're losing their
memory on the front part of the brain
and the temporal the size of the brain
because you know there's a lot of
cholesterol as part of the
myelin white matter of the rain you hear
oh yeah they did an MRI
um magnetic resonance imaging and they
say I have
um I I have um I'm losing the white
matter my brainer demolinization well
that means you're losing the cholesterol
in your brain
because you've been following the
doctor's advice on diet and drugs
and they're getting it all wrong okay so
I know she wants me to take those
starting and I say no I don't take any
medication I exercise I run I swim I do
everything what am I doing wrong the my
cholesterol went up that's my only
question
okay well that means you're sexy because
cholesterol makes up 95 of female
hormones so if your cholesterol is that
high enough
I'm 77 I'll be on that you're 130.
77 90 beyond that I I just want not to
be uh my kids
yeah we want you to get to be 130. as
long as my brain works fine and then my
body functions so so I shouldn't worry
that my my um LDL is 198.
in my triglycerides is 99
and what else oh the A1C is five five
point five okay good now how's your
memory
it's it's good it's not as good as it
used to be but it's it's yeah okay how
many times how many times you wake up at
night to urinate once three times five
times once for sure sometimes once in a
while I sleep my eight hours without
waking up okay good what about
um
um has your voice changed any
no just now with the allergies that I've
got and my voice is better today
yesterday I couldn't speak
okay
um do you have any ring in your ears
ancient I just ring in your ears any
balance
once in a blue moon
oh okay every once in a while all right
yeah okay well keep going like you're
going you're getting more good things
and bad things and so let's go there
call us every week or every two weeks
and you know keep in touch and we'll
kind of walk you through this but you
know you can have obviously approaches
to the skull squeezing the 12 pairs of
cranial nerve squeezing the spinal cord
causing a lot of this kind of stuff but
um uh if you're taking all these
nutrients this should uh all
be good okay so okay
all right thank you thank you Gloria and
Dr Wallach real quick we've got a female
she's 47 years old five foot three 175
pounds going through hot flashes
hormonal imbalances
those are the only conditions that she's
experiencing no blood pressure issues no
blood sugar issues what would you
recommend for her okay at 170 pounds
more to give up all the bad foods no
fried foods no process me some oils no
glutens no wheat no butter I know so
sugar no carburetor drinks uh no
buckwheat even the carbonated water's
got to go because it neutralizes stomach
acid so you can't absorb minerals and
digest food
and then I wanted to have two healthy
brain and heart pasture months two
healthy brand heart passionate about the
photos everything twice a day she weighs
170 pounds right okay then I wanted to
have two bottles of months of the MSM so
you can take three at breakfast lunch at
dinner time they're going to support and
promote Mains repair car Leisure
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between vertebrae bone makes your
bone of cell skin artery walls and all
that kind of stuff and then because
she's having hot flashes I want her to
get our xerofem I want to take three of
those twice a day and that will give her
ovaries what they need to make hormones
to balance that out so she's not having
those problems which are probably
hormonally
um related
um
but she doesn't need to eat at 170
pounds
um two to three eggs twice a day with
soft jokes not hard-boiled not fried and
let's see here I also wanted to have at
lunch time uh one or two of our chewable
I-26 tablets they taste like vanilla ice
cream okay even little kids like them
you know say right on the label provides
25 percent of the daily requirement of
cholesterol
you require cholesterol cholesterol
makes up
95 percent of the weight of female
hormones 95 of the weight of male
hormones
25 of your brain and 25 percent of your
spinal cord any Doctor Who says to stay
away from cholesterol should have their
licensees suspended or even taken away
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and we greatly greatly
appreciate you I know you need to get on
to your next program thank you so much
folks
you heard it cholesterol is not our
enemy cholesterol is required and is
what's needed 95 percent
of our hormones
estrogen testosterone 25 of our brain
weight is cholesterol
if you take that away
it's only makes it's like common sense
you you take away the cholesterol that
the brain needs what's going to happen
to the brain
it's going to stop functioning the way
we want it to
you take cholesterol away and it's 95 I
mean it's needed for our hormones and
hormone balance
and then you've got eggs that have been
demonized and we wonder why everybody's
going crazy
okay that's those are my words doctor
not Dr Wallace but I just want to thank
you all for joining us here on daily
with Doc if I could get my co-hosts up
with me I would greatly appreciate it we
have Phyllis Anderson and Ruth Ellen
Sanchez Sherry Browning Marilyn Sarah F
also we have foreign with us so
everybody it takes a team it takes
different skills to be able to put a
program like this together to be able to
build a business and that's what we do
we use what's called Advanced team
building in building our businesses as
certified holistic health coaches
and youngevity Associates
the we use youngevity products as
Solutions
to a problem that is prevalent around
the world around the world
nutrient deficiencies
are impacting lives impacting families
impacting communities they're impacting
our world everyone and fortunately we
have a supply of those plant-derived
minerals those prehistoric minerals that
will last thousands of years that we
want to make sure that we share with
people around the world
if you have a heart for people
if you want to make an additional income
stream if you have skills that you want
to put to use as part of a team get back
with the person that share this program
with you
tell them hey you know I think I want
some more information about what it is
that I can do to help build awareness
of nutrient deficiencies how they impact
life and the solution to restoring
healthier communities around the world
my name is Becca Dukes the hostess of
this program daily with Doc I am very
honored to have my co-hosts with me who
are here as support each and every day
for myself and those that
contact us and
thank you thank you team
Rebecca for impacting my life yes ma'am
what am I forgetting
we are not going to be on my uh
Wednesday Thursday or Friday of this
week and we will see everybody next week
and Becca I'm not gonna forget I'm
taking a vacation folks she needs that
Rebecca needs to break
and we all love working with Rebecca as
much as she loves us
well thank you so much
thank you thank you you're welcome
everyone out in YouTube world thank you
we will miss you too sportus
um and Rumble and Facebook and all of
those that are here with us live on
daily with Doc on daily with Doc live
zoo no daily
daily with Doc zoom.com
um you can find all of our replays for
our past almost three years now that
include
ass doc live so I got to keep all those
words right
on daily with doc.com
you'll also find a store there that's
for the people that have not spoken to
anybody about youngevity or Dr Wally
feel free to use our store feel free to
use this as a resource to help spread
the news the message of hope that there
are things that we can do as empowered
individuals to help
ourselves and our families and our
communities not just survive but Thrive
until next time bye for now mwah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you